معنا في الاستديو الباحث الاول بمركز
الجزيره للدراسات الدكتور لقاء مكي نريد
ان نعلق بدايه على الموقف الامريكي لانه
حينما نفذت الضربات
الاولى قال مسؤول عسكري للجزيره ان
الضربات
انتهت ثم اذا بهم يعقبون ذلك بضربه جديده
والهدف لكل هذه الضربات هو الردع
فقط طبيعه الضربات كانت توحي بانها لاغراض
الردع وليس للتدمير الشامل طبعا هي دمرت
بعض الاماكن لان الاهداف كانت حوالي 60
هدف وبالتالي كان هناك بنك اداف كبير لكن
حجم التدمير الحقيقي غير
معروف قصه الرادار المنسي في قاعده
الديلمي اللي قصف اليوم الفجر يعني وكان
يبدو لم يدمر بشكل كامل ودمر الان يعني
انا حقيقه هذا يحتاج الى ربما اعاده نظر
عسكريه كيف
يمكن اتمام عمليه والقول انها تمت ثم يخرج
الامريكيون ليقولوا انها لم تتم بشكل جيد
وضربناه مره اخرى هذه امر يعني يحتاج الى
نقاش لكن في كل الحالات الحوثيون قالوا ان
قاعده الديلمي اصلا غير شغاله ايضا هذه
مساله تحتاج الى الى اعاده نظر او مصدر
مستقل لكن في كل الحالات هذه الضربات لن
توقف الحوثي والدليل انه بعد الضربه
الاولى الرئيسيه استهدفت سفينه روسيه او
تحمل النفط الروسي
ولم تصب لكنها كانت القنبله قريبه بمعنى
ان الحوثي ما زال لديه القدره على تهديد
الملاحه
والسفن المتجهه الى اسرائيل كما اعلن
وربما يضيف الى ذلك قائمه اهداف اخرى قد
تشمل هذه المره السفن البريطانيه
والامريكيه او التي تتعامل مع بريطانيا
وامريكا في دلاله الاعلان الامريكي
الاعلان الامريكي يتحدث
عن دول شاركت لكن لم يتحدث عن حجم
مشاركتها وترك ذلك للدول نفسها منها
البحرين على سبيل المثال نعم ما الذي يقرا
في ذلك هذه طبعا طبيعه المشاركه حقيقه هو
قال الرئيس الامريكي انها غير عمليات ا
بمعنى لم تشارك في في الرمي يعني في اطلاق
النار لكنها قد تكون شاركت في الاستخبارات
مثلا في الدعم اللوجستي مثلا في عناصر على
الارض ربما يكون لها لا نعرف لكن شاركت في
العمليه بشكل عام وايراد البحرين بحد ذاته
او بالحقيقه مشاركه البحرين الى جانب دول
محدوده بالحقيقه في هذه العمليه بالذات
كان غريبا وملفتا لان الدوله الخليجيه
الوحيده التي شاركت دون عن دول الاخرى
المعنيه بالقضيه اليمنيه مثل الامارات
والسعوديه وكلاهما لم يشاركا خصوصا
السعوديه لديها ساحل طويل الدوله العربيه
لانه ايضا يعني مثلا مصر بسبب قناه السويس
معنيه ميه جدا ولم تشارك اعربت عن القلق
كذلك السعوديه انا اعتقد ان المشاركه هذه
قيل في البدايه انها بسبب وجود الاسطول
الخامس لكن هذا لا يكفي للمشاركه العمليات
وهذه امر خطير حقيقه لان البحرين تضع
نفسها في هذه الحاله في موضع اولا
الاستهداف من قبل الحوثي باعتبارها مشاركه
والدوله الوحيده القريبه جغرافيا من من
اليمن طيب فيما يتعلق بال رد الفعل يعني
الان بعد الضربه الاولى والضربه الثانيه
الحوثيون يقولون انهم سيردون نعم وسيرد
على الاهداف الامريكيه والبريطانيه تحديدا
في الى اي نقطه سياخذ ذلك هذا التوتر في
البحر الاحمر هل هل نتحدث الان عن مشاركه
اكثر من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وربما
دول اخرى ا يتطور النزاع بين الحوثيين
والولايات المتحده وبريطانيا ليشمل دولا
اخرى في على سبيل المثال طبعا هو التصريح
الحوثي قال المصالح الامريكيه والبريطانيه
المصالح نعم المصالح وهذا يشمل البحر
والبر بمعنى ما لدى الامريكيين
والبريطانيين من مصالح بما فيها النفطيه
في المنطقه ونحن نعرف ان المصالح
الامريكيه في السعوديه مثلا او في
الامارات والبريطانيه طبعا كبيره بالتالي
هل ان الحوثي يعد ولا ننسى ان الاعداد
يحتاج وقت يعني لا لا اعتقد ان الحوثي حتى
لولايات المتحده يحتاجون وقت يعني
بالنهايه التخطيط العسكري وتهيئه السلاح
وجمع الاستخبارات او المعلومات لذلك قد
يكون هناك اهداف للحوثي تتعدى السفن سواء
البريطانيه امريكيه اسرائيليه الى اخره
تتعدى السفن وتتعدى البحر الاحمر الى
مصالح امريكيه في الدول المحيطه شكرا
جزيلا الباحث الاول بمركز الجزيره
للدراسات الدكتور لقاء
مكي